c'est vrai je me dis est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu delphine toi tu es
magnifique c'est vraiment comme voilà
toutes magnifiques d'ailleurs est ce que
toi quand tu étais miss qu'en maintenant
voilà dans le travail ce que tu as déjà
eu des débours d'eau qui tombent donc
chauffé qui tombe est tombée des sms ou
qu'ils tombent et que oui oui oui en
règle général les maires ont des mains
baladeuses ça c'est vrai pendant les
maires quand on fait les parfums les
politiques je vais chez vous pour faire
les photos à machin donc effectivement
c'est au niveau de passer au niveau là
et puis à la fin de la photo ça descend
mais voilà avant donc maintenant je sais
comment faire dès que je sens qu'elle
descend ou qu'elle veut descendre et
bien et bien je la remets en place et je
le regarde et eux ça tu vois déjà ça
c'est
incroyable on va refaire toutes les
villes que tu as fait ton mal plus
bien sûr de moins en moins ça en fait
avec les jeunes miss parce que
effectivement je pense qu'ils savent et
toi tu le veux rien dire tu dis quoi
dans ces cas-là ce que tu était gêné non
je dis rien mais ça va gêner c'est le
jeu remonte la main et la personne n'a
compris j'ai la rage la remonte
fermement et c'est tout c'est fou
apprécie donc pas déjà eu un normand
généralement les les hommes qui ont
beaucoup de pouvoir les hommes très
riches j'ai déjà eu plusieurs demandes
en mariage non avec des zones même très
très très vieux quand j'avais 20 ans un
homme de 70 ans 75 je suis allé manger
avec lui et je sais pas d'ailleurs ce
qui devient et il m'a dit ça beau
c'est vrai que en fait
ben ça faisait pas longtemps que j'étais
sorti de miss france donc je cherchais
un peu des plans pour travailler et où
il a dit tu donc allé déjeuner ensemble
il m'avait dit que je pouvais être un
peu égérie de sa marque d'ailleurs j'ai
même plus que c'était comme marc et
après au bout d'un moment il dit alors
est ce que tu es en couple et tu sais
moi je suis célibataire si tu veux on
pourrait faire un peu échange de bons
procédés
et en gros c'était de l'argent contre
centre être à ses côtés il a dit moi je
suis seul et puis toi tu as envie d'un
coup de pouce je peux te donner sinon
oui voilà on n'a pas trop envie de ce
coup de pouce
est ce que tout soit retravaillé un jour
il ya un gars ou une fille d'ailleurs
qui vous a fait comprendre qu'il fallait
faire débat béatrice
oui dans
parfois c'est un peu flou un peu voilà
c'est jamais dit directement mais assis
quand j'avais 18 ans mon agent de
l'époque m'avait envoyé un casting et je
me suis retrouvé en fait chez un
réalisateur qui était assez connu il ya
quelques années et il me demande mais tu
es sûr que tu as 18 ans et j'étais très
naïve à l'époque je comprenais pas
pourquoi il assistait location ou quoi
il me dit il me dit que je ressemble à
sa fille de 9 ans qui était seule dans
une photo là et ils me disent si tu veux
tu restes dormir ici tu pars demain
quand tu veux tranquillement
j'ai dit non merci j'ai eu un petit peu
peur j'ai décliné je suis parti mais
c'est sinon c'est jamais aussi frontale
que ça en tout cas